On June 25th, a court in the United
Kingdom heard about how a 14-year-old
British girl was once told, quote, "This
is what white girls are for." before
being sexually assaulted by a Muslim
teen around her age. In the victim's own
words, quote, "He said it was my own
fault. I'd led him on. I shouldn't have
walked around in what I was dressed in.
I deserved it, and that is what white
girls were for." He would also refer to
her as his white slut. The same court
heard about how another Muslim man after
having his way with another British girl
also called her the same word as well as
a dirty bitch
before spitting at her and laughing.
Now, what's striking about these
revelations is that the very same logic
and verbatim words have been used by
legions of sexual asalants of a certain
religion who tend to see the females of
a certain race as nymphomaniacal
masochists who want nothing else in life
but to be degraded, used, and abused.
Here are but a few more examples. In
2014, a Muslim man explained to another
British woman why he was sexually
assaulting her. You white women are good
at it, said he, between her crying and
struggling. That of course is just
another variant of this is what white
girls are for, as that other more recent
UK courtroom heard on June 25th. In
2020, another British woman revealed
that her Muslim molesters called her a
white c
and a white whore and a white bitch.
In 2019, another court heard how a
British girl was quote passed around
like a piece of meat among her Muslim
asalants.
Speaking now as an adult, the court
heard how she was quote raped on a dirty
mattress above a takeaway and forced to
perform sex acts in a churchyard and how
one of her abusers quote urinated on her
in an act of humiliation afterward. In
2018, another British woman was
trafficked to Morocco where she was
sexually assaulted by dozens of men.
They quote made me believe I was nothing
more than a slut and a white whore. She
recollects they treated me like a leper,
apart from when they wanted sex. I was
less than human to them. I was rubbish.
In 2015, another Muslim man called a
13-year-old girl a little white slag,
British slang for promiscuous woman,
before forcibly devirginizing her. In
2013, not only did Dr. Taj Har, a
British imam, confirmed that the
majority of the UK's imams promote
grooming rings. In his words, he said,
"Muslim men are taught that women are
quote second-class citizens little more
than cattle or possessions over whom
they have absolute authority, and that
the imams preach a doctrine that quote
denigrates all women, but treats whites
with particular contempt." There's
certainly no doubting that last point.
While this phenomenon manifests itself
with extreme regularity in that bastion
of diversity, the UK, it's ultimately
less about being British and more about
being white. The proof is that the same
thing is happening all across Europe.
Thus, in Germany in 2016, a group of
Muslim migrants stalked a 25-year-old
German woman and hurled quote filthy
insults at her and taunted her for sex.
Then they explained their logic. German
girls are just there for sex, said day
before reaching into her blouse and
groping her. In 2016, another Muslim man
who almost killed his 25-year-old German
victim while raping her and while
shouting Allah afterwards inquired if
she liked it. In 2016 in Australia, a
Muslim cabbie groped and insulted his
female passengers, including by saying,
quote, "All Australian women are sluts
and deserve to be raped."
Now the bigger problem is that this
issue is not limited to or a byproduct
of the modern era. From the very start
of Islam 14 centuries ago, Muslim men
have always portrayed European women,
even chased nuns, as both sexually
desirable and sexually promiscuous by
nature. And as usual, it all traces back
to Muhammad. As Ahmed Mhbul, a western
academic of Muslim origin,
euphemistically writes, quote, "The
Byzantines as a people were considered
fine examples of physical beauty and
youthful slaves and slave girls of
Byzantine origins were highly valued.
The Arabs appreciation of the Byzantine
female has a long history indeed. For
the Islamic period, the earliest
literary evidence we have is a hadith
saying of the prophet, Muhammad is said
to have addressed a newly converted
Arab. Would you like the girls of Benu
al- Assar? Benu al- Osar can be
translated as a fair-haired and/or
skinned people. Now, despite this
academic's fine take of the Arabs
appreciation of Byzantine women, who
essentially represented the Europeans
nearest to Arabia, Muhammad's question
was meant to entice the man to join the
Tabuk campaign against the Byzantine and
reap its rewards. That is the sexual
enslavement of fair women. Indeed, right
from the start, European women, again
typified by neighboring Byzantine women,
became the Muslim world's quote
beautiful fem fatal who makes men lose
their self-control. To quote another
academic, Nedya Maria Elshik, author of
Byzantium, viewed by the Arabs. She
continues, quote, "Our Arab sources show
not Byzantine women, but writer images
of these women who served as symbols of
the eternal female, constantly a
potential threat, particularly due to
blatant exaggerations of their sexual
promiscuity. In our Arabic texts,
Byzantine women are strongly associated
with sexual immorality. While the one
quality that our Muslim sources never
deny is the beauty of Byzantine women,
the image that they create in describing
these women is anything but beautiful.
Their depictions are occasionally
excessive, virtually caricatures
overwhelmingly negative. Such fevered
fantasies, which are clearly far from
Byzantine reality, continues alik,
existed only in the minds of Muslim men,
and quote, must be recognized for what
they are, attempts to denigrate and
defame a rival culture. In fact, in
Byzantium, women were expected to be
retiring, shy, modest, and devoted to
their families and religious
observances. The behavior of most women
in Byzantium was a far cry from the
depictions that appear in Arabic
sources. Indeed, for example, Abu Oman
al- Jahis, an Abbassad court scholar
born around 776, insisted that the
females of Constantinople were the quote
most shameless women in the whole world.
They find sex more enjoyable and are
prone to adultery. Writing about 150
years later, Abdul Jabar, another
prominent Muslim scholar born around
935, claimed that quote, "Adultery is
commonplace in the cities and markets of
Byzantium." So much so that even the
nuns from the convents went out to the
fortresses to offer themselves to monks.
And just like all white women today, not
just Brits are viewed in this
unflattering manner, so too were all
white women then, not just Byzantines,
viewed as depraved hussies by nature.
Thus, during the later crusading era, in
a written exerpt that goes to great, if
not pornographic lengths, Muhammad bin
Hammed, also known as Alzahhani, a
celebrated Persian court scholar and
poet born around 1125, explained how he
once saw a ship approaching, which
contained, quote, 300 lovely Frankish
women full of youth and beauty. The
flattery ends there, and the fantasizing
begins. Quote, they glowed with aror for
carnal intercourse. They were all
lentuous harlots, proud and scornful,
who took and gave, foul-fed and sinful,
making love and selling themselves for
gold. With nasal voices and fleshy
thighs, blue-eyed and greyeyed, they
dedicated as a holy offering what they
kept between their thighs. They
maintained that they could make
themselves acceptable to God. By no
better sacrifice than this, they made
themselves targets for men's darts.
After Saladin conquered Jerusalem from
the Franks in 1187, this same Elisfahani
who was present in age 62 then launched
into yet another Sato masochistic tirade
extolling the sexual debasement of
European women and children about 8,000
of whom were enslaved. Quote, how many
well-guarded women were profained then?
How many queens were ruled and nubile
girls married and noble women given away
and miserly women forced to yield
themselves and women who had been kept
hidden meaning nuns stripped of their
modesty and free women occupied meaning
penetrated and precious ones used for
hard work and pretty things put to the
test and virgins dishonored and proud
women defflowered and happy ones made to
weep. How many noble menus lords took
them as concubines? How many ardent men
blazed for one of them and celibates
were satisfied by them and thirsty men
sadated by them and turbulent men able
to give vent to their passion. How many
lovely women were the exclusive property
of one man? How many great ladies were
sold at low prices and lofty ones abased
and those accustomed to thrones dragged
down.
In short, just as many Muslim men see
Western women as pieces of meat, wanted
nyomomaniacs that are dying to be used
and abused, so too did Islam's earliest
luminaries always see and describe
European women thus. It's a real ongoing
problem. But if you dare notice it,
especially where it's widespread in
Western Europe in general, the UK in
particular, you might just get yourself
arrested.